no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola mi nombre es hi marista soy
etnomusicólogo tengo 26 años y soy de
aquí de ir algo y mi acercamiento a la
música fue gracias a este instrumento la
gaita
hace 7 años conocí a una chica italiana
venía de padua me habló que en su país
había grandotas y chiquitas que las
hacían con piel del chivo que los
pastores la tocaban yo quedé
completamente asombrado de todo lo que
ella me decía
injustamente una semana antes de
emprender el vuelo tuve la oportunidad
de ir con ella a tlacotalpan veracruz
tierra del son jarocho ahí conocí este
instrumento
el marin vol
[Música]
en el son jarocho cumple la función del
bajo
este instrumento pertenece a una lista
que muchos mexicanos desconocemos que es
la lista de instrumentos mexicanos en
peligro de extinción
sí porque en el país no sólo se extingue
la col ot el jaguar también se extinguen
nuestras lenguas nuestras tradiciones
nuestra cultura y con ello nuestra
música
quise investigar desde la raíz la música
mexicana me fui desde lo prehispánico
ahí me encontré con la novedad de que
cada vez eran menos las personas que se
dedicaban a la fabricación de
instrumentos prehispánicos así que tuve
que empezar a fabricar lacio quedando
impresionado por aquellas que producen
el sonido de algún animal como éste
el grillo
el jaguar
en la serpiente de cascabel
el búho
el sapo
las aves
i
tiene
y estos otros que no son made in china
son hechos en mexico por nuestros
ancestros hace mil años los que
funcionan a base de agua
en la prepa era conocido como el indito
como el de la música de la selva había
crecido en una generación de compañeros
que escuchaban arctic monkeys timing
para la los strokes y mantenían su
música originaria tal cual su nombre
como sus raíces enterradas en 2014 tuve
la oportunidad de hacer mi primer
trabajo como etnomusicólogo al irme a la
sierra de san luís a investigar unos
instrumentos muy chistosos
estos los instrumentos de la música
chiquita si no son de juguete en verdad
son instrumentos ceremoniales en san
luís se acompañan de esta arpa
recuerdo haber llegado al pueblo
únicamente con las fotografías y
preguntarle a todos disculpe los conoce
dónde puedo comprarlos los han visto hay
alguien que los toque y todos todos
todos me decían que no hasta que llegue
a una tienda
pregunte por los instrumentos y me
dijeron sí sí creo que don eulalio los
toca para llegar a casa de don eulalio
tuve que pasar por una hora de sol y
camino en la tierra hasta que por fin
llegué le pregunté por los instrumentos
y me dijo que no que no los conocía que
no los tocaba pero que si le ayudaba con
una jornada de siembra podía llevarme
con alguien que sí que si los tenía así
fue y al atardecer me invitó a comer
al entrar a su casa me mostró los
instrumentos me dijo que se tocaban hace
mucho tiempo en san luís cuando un niño
moría y las mujeres descalzas iban
tocando los instrumentos acompañando en
procesión al niño hacia el panteón
ellos en su lengua le dicen la música se
cansa la música de los chiquitos
hay cerca
tenemos a los panes que utilizan está
flauta
afortunadamente hay grabaciones de la
flauta para mí pero desafortunadamente
ya no hay ejecutantes también tenemos
este el arco de los tepehuanos
que lo utilizan en la ceremonia de
siembra imitando la leyenda del venado y
el conejo la cual dice que ambos
lanzaban alrededor del fuego y cansado
el venado le pidió la suspensión nasal
al conejo y es por eso que las personas
danzas descalzas imitando al conejo su
sonido sus sonidos este
[Música]
y la gente danza al ritmo del arco
percutor tepehuano
ese viaje que les comenté al principio
en tlacotalpan veracruz me hizo
recapacitar si tenía que irme a italia
para estudiar la gaita o quedarme en mi
país e investigar los instrumentos
autóctonos la respuesta es obvia
este otro muy singular
es de la sierra de chihuahua es de los
rarámuris el último ejecutante narra que
su abuelo lo tocaba cuando iba a cazar
venados pero debido a la cacería ilegal
desapareció el venado y ya no había por
qué hacer la ceremonia así que el
instrumento quedó en desuso
su sonido es éste
i
el vamos
y aunque no lo crean el calentamiento
global igual afecta a los instrumentos
musicales hay uno en especial que se
llama tenaris que me ha costado mucho el
trabajo conseguir que hace el sonido
de una sonaja lo tocan en sonora para la
danza del venado
se construye con con los capullos de la
mariposa cuatro espejos una mariposa que
sólo tiene como vida ocho días
el capullo lo podemos encontrar en los
árboles y debido a que los a que la
temperatura ha aumentado en son ahora
cada vez es más difícil encontrar
encontrar el capullo de la mariposa
cuatro espejos
pienso que para poder reintroducir la
música autóctona
a nuestra sociedad hay que luchar con
dos factores uno
el clasismo y el otro el malinchismo
una de mis metas de vida es tener un
museo donde los visitantes tengan acceso
y conocimiento a los instrumentos que
ahí se exponen debido a que últimamente
estudian laudería para construir mis
propios instrumentos me gustaría que los
interesados tuvieran la oportunidad de
fabricar los instrumentos
y un espacio donde los ejecutantes de
música folclórica puedan ser escuchados
desde la antigua edad
el hombre ha desarrollado las artes como
la escultura la pintura la danza con la
finalidad de darle identidad alguna
alguna parte del mundo
para la inmortalidad para la
trascendencia
así nuestros ancestros nuestros pueblos
originarios
desarrollaron estos instrumentos estos
ritmos para darle identidad a algún
lugar del país
para darle un sello y de nosotros
depende que nuestra música mexicana no
quede en el olvido muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]